dernier coup de gueule
il ya une semaine avant le coup d'envoi
non non avec mon équipe sera un problème
africain et une mission à l'extérieur
parce que je crois que quand on a on est
manager dans le privé on a une
organisation civile mais quand même à
caractère militaire et le chef il garde
une vieille notion peut-être ça c'est
important pour vous qui voulez greffer
des choses pour moi le chef c'est celui
qui crie le plus fort qui capte le plus
fort et c'est celui qui se fait
respecter non mais ça va avec le côté
également intellectuelle mais sur le
terrain ça se passe comme ça un r 1000 r
ça je suis sûr mais non mais non mais je
je pense c'est pour vous at on déjà pour
vous baril s'est ainsi
story je voudrais vous dire aussi par
ici je voudrais vous dire quand même que
le courage moral beaucoup d'hommes
politiques que l'on mais moi le courage
moral va avec le poil physique 1 et
certains ont beaucoup de courage moral
mais de courage physique il ya pas grand
chose ça mais et c'est là où devait
intervenir vous devez greffer une puce
de téléphone et que pourquoi les échos
un pentium de courage physique est ce
que je veux c'est un autre monde je
pourrais simplement diable ne sait pas
c'est que c'est un personnage historique
après mon capitaine
mais ce qui était un personnage
historique ce je trouve que je ne doute
pas de votre courage physique puisque je
connais un petit peu quand même votre
carrière mais vous avez sans doute l'âge
venant intégrer de du maintien de
l'ordre tout ce qu'il ya de pire c'est
la seule chose qui est intégrée
c'est-à-dire l'idée est justement de la
force appliquée dans la loire l'idée que
grosso modo vous êtes là en position de
supérieur c'est non pas du tout quoi non
je voudrais vous dire une chose vraiment
on est nombreux il ya des dames qui sont
ici le premier problème qu'est ce que
vous voulez tous vous voulez tous cas
sécurité voulaient sortir tranquille
vous voulez vivre tranquillement vous
aimez pas la sécurité vous pouvez
retrouver votre voiture le départ
affirmé arye leur message politique mais
tout le monde le sait aujourd'hui mais
pas dangereux quel prix on peut d'abord
l'on veut nous essayons bouvier a menacé
en sortant ce soir vous intégrez en vous
tirant votre portefeuille vous allez
dire merci non j'appellerais la police
dans sept métiers vous a fait qu'ils
sont enterrés la police républicaine qui
a aussi joué dur de voir monsieur barry
et je trouve terrible
ces matériels ces discussions là
on a besoin non mais je trouve ça
formidable je croyais qu aujourd'hui la
police était définitivement républicaine
qu'elle comprenait que pour faire
appliquer la loi il faut l'appliquer à
soi-même monsieur barry vous n'avez pas
changé depuis 1968 je vais voir avec les
pavés est en train de mettre le feu aux
voitures alors que nous on veut des
campagnes tranquille on veut que les
enfants aillent à l'école on veut qu'ils
aient pas de pédophiles n'ont pu ni sur
les réseaux internet et c'est ce que
demandent tous les gendarmes et coup de
rouge
que de rejet année coup de rouge je
comprends pas question que de rouge
ouais je bois pas je ne fume pas jamais
bu jamais fumé avant c'est pour ça alors
mes chers bien cerbère
dernier coup de bluff et reviens y monte
mais c'est terrible je fais des coups de
fusil
secret défense dans les coups de blues
y'en a pas vous n'êtes jamais de coup de
blues non c'est formidable jacques nom
des gens qui ont jamais de coup de blues
c'est pas moi je peux pas répondre là
parce que chaque fois
[Applaudissements]
le fait d'être fliqué sans arrêt comme
ça moi je trouve ça insupportable
j'aime pas la police quoi moi
c'est comme ça même si un avis ses fans
avides you parce que je n'aime pas non
plus les gangsters j'aime pas non plus
les mafiosi génial en plus tout ça mais
y'a un moment donné où il ya collision
quoi il ya collusion plutôt que
collision il ya collision avec moi en
tout cas j'ai jamais pu appeler les
flics quand j'avais à régler un problème
j'ai été voir le mec j'ai parlé si
c'était vraiment grave ils sont jamais
déplacés jamais et la fois que je me
suis trouvé dans des commissariats en
garde à vue où tout j'ai vu des choses
atroces et dégueulasse mais profondément
sous le coup de la loi avec des gens qui
étaient sous le couvert de l'ordre de
leurs képis ray des tas de choses
humiliantes profondément salle quand on
était avec l'histoire du dal il y avait
50 cars de flics pas des gens comme vous
pas des des gendarmes correct d'accord
poli propres sur eux et on les paye
c'est nous qui les payons quoi et à un
moment donné j'ai demandé un flic quand
j'étais en garde à vie je vais dit mais
vous n'êtes pas gardiens de la paix une
non monsieur je suis fonctionnaire de
police attend c'est quoi ça gardiens de
la paix pour moi ça voulait dire quelque
chose mais fonctionnaires de police va
te faire voir à quoi va te faire voir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
finale andy tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus